it's four and a half years since the
british people voted to
take back control of their money their
borders their laws
and their waters and to leave the
european union
and earlier this year we fulfilled that
promise and that we left
on january the 31st with that oven ready
deal
since that time we've been getting on
with our agenda enacting
the points-based immigration system that
you voted for that will come into force
on january the first
doing free trade deals with 58 countries
around the world and preparing the new
relationship
with the eu and there have been plenty
of people who have told us
that the challenges of the kovid
pandemic have made this work
impossible and that we should extend the
transition period and incur
yet more delay and i rejected that
approach
precisely because beating kovid
is our number one national priority
and i wanted to end any extra
uncertainty and to give this country
the best possible chance of bouncing
back strongly
next year and so i'm very pleased to
tell you uh this afternoon
that we have completed the biggest trade
deal yet
worth 660 billion pounds a year
a comprehensive canada style free trade
deal
between the uk and the eu a deal
that will protect jobs across this
country a deal will allow
goods uk goods and components to be sold
without tariffs and without quotas
in the eu market a deal which will if
anything
allow our companies and our exporters to
do even more business with our european
friends and yet
which achieves something that the people
of this country
instinctively knew was doable
but which they were told was impossible
we've taken back control
of our laws and our destiny we've taken
back control of
every jot and tittle of our regulation
in a way that is complete and unfettered
from january the 1st we are outside the
customs union
and outside the single market british
laws will be made solely
by the british parliament interpreted by
uk
judges sitting in uk courts
and the jurisdiction of the european
court of justice will come
to an end we will be able to set our own
standards
to innovate in the way that we want to
originate new frameworks for the sectors
in which this country leads the world
from biosciences to financial services
artificial intelligence and beyond
we'll be able to decide how and where
we're going to stimulate new jobs and
new hope
with free ports new green industrial
zones
we'll be able to cherish our landscape
and our environment
in the way we choose backing our farmers
backing british food and agricultural
production
and for the first time since 1973
we will be an independent coastal state
with full control
of our waters with the uk's share of
fish in our waters rising substantially
from roughly
half today to closer to two-thirds
in five and a half years time after
which there is
no theoretical limit beyond those placed
by science or
conservation on the quantity of our own
fish that we can fish
in our waters and to get ready
for those for that moment those fishing
communities will be
helped with a big 100 million pro pound
program
to modernize their fleets and the fish
processing
industry and i want to stress that
uh although of course uh the the
arguments with our european friends and
partners were
were sometimes uh fierce this is i
believe a good deal
for the whole of uh of europe
uh and uh for our friends and partners
as well
because it will not be a bad thing in my
view for the eu to have a
prosperous and dynamic uh and contented
uk on your doorstep and it will be a
good thing
uh it will be it will drive jobs and
prosperity across
the whole continent and i think it'd be
a bad thing
if we in the uk do things differently or
take a different approach
uh to legislation because in so many
ways our basic
goals are the same and
in the context of this giant free trade
zone
that we're jointly creating the stimulus
of regulatory competition will i think
benefit
us both and if one side believes it's
somehow being
unfairly undercut by the other
then subject to independent third-party
arbitration and provided the
measures are proportionate we can either
of us
decide as sovereign equals to protect
our consumers or businesses but this
treaty explicitly envisages
that such action should only happen
infrequently
and the concepts of uniformity and
harmonization are banished in favor of
mutual respect and mutual recognition
and
free trade and for for squaring that
circle
uh for finding uh the the philosopher's
stone that's enabled us to
to do this i want to thank president
vandalian ursula wonderlion of the
european commission uh our brilliant
negotiators led by
uh lord frost uh michelle barnier
on the eu side as stephanie riso
as well as oliver lewis tim barrow
lindsay appleby many others
their work will be available for
scrutiny
followed by a parliamentary vote uh i
hope on december
the 30th this agreement this deal
above all means certainty it means
certainty for the aviation industry
and the hauliers who have suffered so
much in the covid pandemic it means
certainty for the police the border
forces the security services
all those we rely on across europe to
keep us all safe
it means certainty for our scientists
who will be able to work together
and continue to work together on great
collective
projects because although we want in the
uk to be a science
superpower we also want to be a
collaborative
science superpower and above all
it means certainty for business uh
from uh financial services to our world
leading manufacturers
our our car industry uh certainty uh for
all those uh who are working in high
skilled jobs
uh and in firms and factories across
the whole the whole country because
there will be no uh palisade of
tariffs on january the first and
there'll be no
non-tariff barriers to to trade instead
there will be a giant free trade zone of
which
we will once be a member and at the same
time
be able to do our own free trade deals
as one
uk whole and entire england
northern ireland scotland wales together
and
i should stress this deal was done by a
huge
negotiating team from every part of the
uk and it will benefit
every part of our united kingdom helping
to unite and level up across the country
and so i say again directly to our eu
friends
and partners i think this deal means a
new stability
and a new certainty in what has
sometimes been a fractious
and difficult relationship we will be
your friend your ally
your supporter and indeed never let it
be
forgotten your number one market
because although we have left the eu
this country
will remain culturally emotionally
historically strategically
geologically attached
to europe not least of course through
the
four million eu nationals who have
requested to settle in the uk
over the last four years and who make an
enormous
contribution to our country and to our
lives
and i say to all of you at home at the
end of this toughest of years
that our focus in the weeks ahead is of
course on
defeating the the pandemic and on
beating coronavirus and rebuilding our
economy and
delivering jobs across the country
and i'm utterly confident that we can
and will do it
we've uh by today we vaccinated almost
000 people and we've also today
resolved a question that has bedeviled
our politics
for decades and it is up to us
all together as a newly and truly
independent nation to
realize the immensity of this
moment and to make the most of it
happy christmas to you all
that's the good news from brussels now
for the sprites